a little bit of a date night tonight  with your wife  absolutely now as you know when one  Hemsworth does something all the  Hemsworth show up and Liam was here  tonight with his ladylove Miley Cyrus  Miley Cyrus stepped out for a rare date  night with her fiance Liam Hemsworth at  the LA premiere of thor ragnarok  the couple appeared happier than ever on  the red carpet Tuesday night  sporting stylish looks to support Liam's  brother Chris Miley you excited for the  movie Miley and Liam stayed close to  each other walking hand in hand into the  TCL Chinese Theatre meanwhile 34  year-old Chris had his leading lady wife  Elsa Pataky by his side the actor told  et all about his kid-free evening the  kids with my grandparents so it's just  the two of us or not yeah very good  essential essential date I do the  Hangout and kind of you know baby with  one another outside of that sort of kids  no idea  [Music]  you